حث زيلينسكي الرئيس بايدن على
القدوم إلى أوكرانيا ، وهو أمر يقول بايدن إنه
لم يتخذ قرارًا بشأنه بعد ، فماذا
تعتقد أن زيارة بايدن لأوكرانيا في
الوقت الحالي ،
أعني أعتقد أنها ستكون رمزية بشكل كبير ،
ولا أرى أي شيء.  بعيدًا عن ذلك ،
أعني من الناحية اللوجستية ، لا أعتقد أنه
يفعل أي شيء ،
ولا أعتقد أنه سيحدث
فرقًا جوهريًا في الطريقة ، دعنا
نقول أن الأوكرانيين
يقاومون الروس ، فهم لا يحتاجون إلى الرئيس
بايدن لإلهامهم.  إعادة القتال من
أجل وطنهم
في وطنهم
أه ولكن أعتقد أنه سيكون
رمزيًا بنفس الطريقة التي ظهر بها
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسون
في كييف وسار في الميدان مع أه
فلاديمير زولينسكي الميدان الرئيسي في  في
هذه المدينة كان الأمر رمزيًا عندما
جاء الرئيس الإستوني عندما جاء الرئيس الليتواني عندما جاء رئيس لاتفيا
عندما جاء الرئيس البولندي ،
لديك قائمة
بقادة العالم الذين أتوا إلى هنا
لإظهار  دعمهم ورئيسهم بايدن
أو بصراحة أي عضو كبير آخر في
نائب رئيس إدارته هاريس
وزير الخارجية بلينكين
وزير الدفاع لويد أوستن لم نر
أي مسؤول إداري كبير يأتي
ليشعر بالرغبة رغم أنه آمن بما يكفي
بالنسبة لهم للقيام بذلك على الرغم من أنه من الواضح
هناك لوجستيات ضخمة متورطة في
كل ذلك ،
لكنك تعلم أنه آمن بشكل عام ،
وأعتقد أن يأتوا ، لا
أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك هجوم صاروخي
روسي على رئيس الولايات المتحدة ولكن ما الذي
ستواجهه الإدارة وتقول
لماذا  قم بإيماءة من هذا القبيل مع
الرئيس بايدن الذي يأتي إلى كييف
عندما يأتي الدعم الحقيقي
بمئات الملايين من الدولارات من الأسلحة
التي سمحت بها الولايات المتحدة بالفعل ،
تعرف ما هو أكثر من
800 مليون دولار من الأسلحة
والمدفعية الثقيلة أه المروحيات
طائرات كاميكازي بدون طيار أو الرئيس بايدن
يقوم بزيارة إلى المفتاح الآن أعتقد أن الآخرين
سيقولون أنه يمكنك المشي ومضغ العلكة
في نفس الوقت الذي  يمكن للرئيس الإلكتروني أن
يقوم بهذه الإيماءة الرمزية بينما
يستمر أيضًا في إرسال
مئات الملايين من الدولارات كمساعدات ،
لكن هذا نوع من الجدل في كلا
الجانبين هنا والذي نراه في أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]